- [Instructor] Let's say we
have two samples of helium gas.
One sample of helium
gas is at temperature T1
and the other sample of helium
gas is at temperature T2.
If T2 is greater than T1,
that means on average,
the particles of helium
gas in the second box
are moving faster than the
particles of helium gas
in the first box.
We can tell the particles
in the second box
are moving faster because on average,
the length of these arrows
indicating the velocity vector
in the box and the right are longer
than the length of the
arrows in the first box.
The equation for kinetic energy
is equal to 1/2 mv squared,
where m is the mass of a particle
and v is the velocity of a particle.
Since the gas particles
in the box on the right
are on average traveling faster
and have higher velocities,
the average kinetic energy
of the particles in the box on the right
is higher than the average kinetic energy
for the particles in the box on the left.
And so the average kinetic energy
is proportional to the temperature.
The higher the temperature,
the higher the average kinetic
energy of the particles.
Instead of gases, let's
look at two metal blocks
made of the same material.
So one of the metal blocks
is at temperature T1
and the other metal block
is at temperature T2.
Let's say the temperature
T2 is greater than T1.
What that means is the
particles in the metal box
on the right are on average moving faster
than the particles in the
metal box on the left.
And that means that the
average kinetic energy
of the particles in the
box on the right is greater
than the average kinetic energy
in the particles in the box on the left.
Also notice, right now
are two pieces of metal
are not touching each other.
So there's a little bit
of space between them.
Next, we bring the two objects
and we put them in
contact with each other.
So now there are collisions
between the particles that touch
and this results in the transfer of energy
from the hotter object
to the cooler object.
So heat flows from the object
at the higher temperature
to the object at the lower temperature.
And so the hot atoms in the
metal object on the right
start to move a little slower,
whereas the colder atoms
in the metal on the left
start to move a little bit faster.
And the transfer of energy continues
until both objects have
the same final temperature.
And we say that thermal
equilibrium has been reached.
So here we have our two objects,
and the two objects are at
the same final temperature,
which means we have reached
thermal equilibrium.
And since we've reached
thermal equilibrium,
there's no more flow of heat
between the two objects,
and since both objects are at
the same final temperature,
that means the average kinetic energy
of the particles in both
objects is now the same.